bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france la première question
pourquoi certains soignants refusent de
se faire vacciner
c'est une bonne question on peut dire
que il ya quand même eu une gestion de
la crise d'abord du gouvernement qui
était assez catastrophique
donc je pense qu'il ya une brosse une
grosse méfiance vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de
tout ça et on voit aussi notamment le
lobbing un petit peu des laboratoires
qui qui manifestement reste sur un
business plutôt qu'une crise sanitaire
puisque si si on était vraiment dans une
crise sanitaire les brevets des vaccins
seraient seraient redistribués à toutes
les entreprises on pourrait produire des
vaccins en masse or aujourd'hui on voit
malheureusement que ce n'est pas le cas
c'est la question vient de le voir un
c'est la question que composer olive et
veyran s est il de la part des soignants
de refuser de se faire vacciner
comprenez vous la question qu'il entend
poser bien sûr je comprends mais
l'éthique vous savez c'est assez marrant
c'est quand gouvernement parle de
d'éthique c'est toujours toujours dans
son sens et je tiens quand même à lui
rappelé qu à la première vague à la
deuxième vague on a menti et
manifestement de beaucoup d'équipements
de protection et la l'éthique ça leur
pose pas problème
donc si vous voulez c'est un petit peu
un discours à deux vitesses où on dit
que l'on culpabilise des soignants
est-ce que ça ça devient assez
insupportable et notamment d' appât de
nombreux médecins qui rekik musée des
plateaux il culpabilise les soignants
alors que ben ces mêmes médecins on les
entendait pas beaucoup lorsque nous
étions habillés avec des sacs poubelles
ou alors avec des masques périmés voilà
notamment dernièrement avec des masques
95 qui arrivent de chine et dont on ne
connaît pas l'efficacité qui n'ont pas
été testés en arrivant en france
donc si vous voulez c'est un petit peu
des discours des discours à deux
vitesses qui commence vraiment à être
vraiment insupportable que pensez vous
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire par
les dirigeants par les grilles petits
français depuis le début de la pandémie
est ce que ça a un peu évolué on va
écouter on voit qu'ils ont pas du tout
irait à tirer deux leçons
nous en tout cas au collectif inter bloc
on demande
des équipements de protection afin qu'un
maximum d'équipements de protection dans
les blocs opératoires ce n'est toujours
pas le cas on est toujours en train de
se battre pour avoir du matériel de
protection notamment des masques ffp2
pour se protéger au maximum durant
durant les procédures on voit créer un
effet puisque certaines sociétés
savantes ni le fait de l'aérosol isation
toujours et encore alors que de
nombreuses études aujourd'hui qui qui
contextualise cet aérosol isation ne pas
en entendre parler puisque
malheureusement il faudra équiper très
largement tous les soignants et
aujourd'hui voilà c'est plutôt ça qu'on
réclame on sait que le vaccin fait
partie d'un arsenal de lutte contre la
corrida on en est certain ça c'est pas
c'est pas le problème mais en tout cas
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas avancer
que que cette histoire de vaccins il
faut voir aussi la base
à la base la protection des soignants
rappelle aussi que à une certaine époque
les soignants qui étaient contaminés par
manque de personnel devaient retourner
travailler les médecins autorisés
le retour au travail puisque c'était
très compliqué il y avait une forte
tension dans les hôpitaux
donc si vous voulez ça pose problème
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas
par expérience dans le passé ça posait
pas problème apparemment manifestement
peut-être l'exécutif pourrait penser à
contraindre le personnel soignant se
faire vacciner
que pensez vous de cette proposition je
pense que c'est pas du tout une bonne
chose il faut il faut laisser le choix
le la vaccination en tout cas doit être
un choix personnel je pense qu'il n'ya
pas que les soignants je pense que la
population aussi les gens sont assez
grands pour pour décider pour pour
eux-mêmes
alors la campagne de vaccination millas
que la majorité des points c'est soit
immunisée contre le coc vite 19
comment ça peut fonctionner si des
personnes qu'ils soignent dans les
hôpitaux ne se font pas vacciner
écoutez déjà et l'on peut déjà se poser
la question c'est est ce que le
gouvernement a assez de doses pour
vacciner tous les souvenirs la
population manifestement ce qui se passe
dans les hôpitaux
c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez de doses
pour soigner pour soigner tout le monde
ou alors on garde des doses pour pour le
vaccin pour la deuxième dose de vaccin
pour certains soignants donc
j'aimais quand même de sérieux doutes
quant à la capacité du gouvernement à
vacciner tout le monde notamment tous
les soignants on rappelle qu on est
assez nombreux à nous on est presque 700
milles infirmiers donc je pense que ça
devient très compliqué je pense et de
ségur de la santé est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a permis de modifier certaines
choses du tout à le séduire de la santé
c etais s'etait une vaste blague
en tout cas pour nous les soignants
quand il parle d'augmentation ça a été
juste un rattrapage du gel du point
d'indicé donc si vous voulez justement
les personnels sont largement en colère
face à cette à toutes ces décisions qui
ont été prises en post de ségur donc si
vous voulez ça a dû ça a dû largement
renforcé les avis des soignants
vis-à-vis de toute cette gestion de la
crise ainsi denis voir merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france
on rappelle que vous êtes président du
collectif inter bloc martial